last week i did a ulife you lose got
that
full word and i challenged green
pewdiepie
and thanos pewdiepie but no one accepted
my challenge
a bunch of cowards so here i am
and here you are smash like to accept
the challenge
scotty florida let's fricken do this
guys
hey another fan of me
[Music]
by the way if i laugh i get three likes
add the likes
that's right i'm fine i'm fine okay
where's that from
[Music]
the legend my highest note
oh my god let me try let me try
[Music]
that was not bad
i love how he's so serious about is he
serious he has to be trolling right
this is a troll
i feel like it's not a troll a classic
meme
a classic meme all right let's keep
going and remember the rules guys
no laughing okay otherwise
okay
that was an amazing edit could this
possibly be
a new meme edit that hasn't been defined
by the duck and grand
day a new template and doesn't involve
stupid marvel
movies that would be great thank you
very much
so far i have one more life guys
come on this is not some kind of game
ah batman like when we get to the bat
cave could i get a little snack
yes shaggy we'll all have a snack
i think i need to re-watch someone oh
batman like when we get to the bat cave
could i get a little snack
yes shaggy we'll all have a snack no
no i will not no i will not i am not
grinning
okay be quiet this is not me laughing or
grinning i am choosing to smile
because i make myself laugh revive one
point
that's right i got two life what do you
want it's my game my rules
be quiet you can't even talk skeptic
it's been sponsored by any any drinking
company want to sponsor me
please this could be you all right hey
guys look it's spiderman chilling on the
road
hey what's going on spider-man oh no
yo-yo is that a car
no no is that thanos car
oh no spider-man he's wearing headphones
spider-man thousands coming oh my god he
has headphones on he can't hear us
oh my god spider-man move you're gonna
die
oh my god
oh wow tanner's car it
is inspired avengers 4 thanos car is in
okay this is really cool i think you
know the video i did
criticizing marvel movies so everyone
lost their marvels for
i'm gonna go ahead and say i was wrong
well i'm not hiding in there if that's
your brilliant plan we're changing
vehicles
trouble with company cars is they have
trackers
did he just say car that does not count
that's not cap gee i wonder what the
meme is going to be
oh wow it's status car
better star badass car is still
kicking it get in
that's right you see a stainless car you
get it
there's no choice why is standards car
still going
hey hey look another marble everything
damn i was wrong marvel is not for
teenagers
they're for hardcore badasses
gwen dies hey look it's me good me
prodigy.exe applause for amazing edit
but the thing is i did the reaction
thing so people would make gifts out of
it so we could ironically share
gifts with each other but instead
everyone treated like a green screen
competition
and you did it wrong okay you just did
it wrong
stop don't stop nagging don't nag no one
likes a [ __ ]
excuse me what is this south park people
that annoy you dude
that sound that sounded
you know second time all right i only
said it once
i'm gonna put on my uh glass of uh of
see through
bs and say that uh he planted that
dude stop don't stop nagging don't nag
no one uses the word neg unless you want
to be racist
how is he still alive to stream on this
platform is beyond me
oh my god yes to catch it
uh sorry i thought you were takashi it
really did look like takashi to be fair
this is the new damn daniel kind of want
to get that hair now just for the memes
what how the [ __ ]
uh lawyer you can see him laugh in vr as
well this reminds me let me show you one
of my favorite clips of all time this
doesn't count
because i've seen it and it's it's so
good
i'm price chloe price because it
summarizes these games so beautifully
jesus put that thing down chillax sista
it's not even loaded
chillax i thought you believed in gun
control yes i believe i should control
the gun
it's the men who need to be checked
so good stupid gun
jesus i shot myself ah i shot myself
back up back up stupid gun wait there's
a clip of me
oh okay i can walk wherever i want i see
surprise ah
oh my god jesus hey look at that
i can make funny clips too surprise
ah oh my god jesus i was genuinely
terrified
she pulled a fast one on me hey more vr
chat i'll take it
he gave me a smoke i can open up my
helmet real quick yeah sure i got you
oh thank you my brother
i think it's time to revisit vr chat
because they're still going with the
ugandan knuckles amazing he gave me a
spoke i can open up my helmet real quick
yeah sure i got you oh thank you my
brother
[Laughter]
great meme okay so i asked brad to send
me some extra clips
so let's see let's see if brad can do
this for us
i hate how that didn't make me laugh it
says i knew it you could add that to me
i feel like i should have cut something
out you know okay
now let's get a good look at you let's
enhance
with the right equipment the image could
be enlarged and sharpened
with the right equipment huh it's an
enhancement program oh an enhancement
program no
everyone has one of those enhanced
section
enhance a6 detail and i think there's
enough to enhance release it to my
screen
enhance the reflection in her eyes let's
run this through video on here
hang on i've been working on this
reflection for someone's reflection
there's a reflection of the man's face
the reflection there's a reflection
zoom in on the mirror you can see your
reflection oh really
can you enhance the image from here can
you enhance him right here can you
enhance it can you enhance it can we
enhance this
wow writing is so creative and original
and people complain about my videos
wait stop stop pause it rotate uh 75
degrees around the vertical please
oh of course as you can do go back to
the park got an image enhancer that can
bitmap
maybe we can use the deep send method to
see into the windows this is the part
where they gotta make up some mumbo
jumbo
yeah the eigen value is off right
he's taking illumination algorithms to
the next level the illumination
algorithms oh my god
enhance enhance enhance freeze and
enhance
bingo we got him
oh come on you could have added a mean
bang all right let's look at the result
hey look i won hurray
of your life you lose everybody let me
know how you guys did
leave a smash like if you lost and leave
a smash like if you want
and i will see you guys in another video
i'm articulating with my hands so you
feel more enticed in the video
alright goodbye
[Music]
you